in the last video on the lungs or the
gas exchange in our bodies or on the
pulmonary system we left off with the
alveolar sacs let me draw one right here
so we have these
alveolar sacs that i talked about and
they're kind of in these little clumps
like this
let me draw a couple of them just you
get the idea and if you remember from
the last video these are kind of where
you know air goes in through our trachea
then that splits up into our bronchi and
then those split into the bronchioles
and then the bronchioles terminate at
these alveoli let me so that's the
alveoli these are these super small sacs
that we talked about in the last video
on the pulmonary system you might want
to watch that video if none of this
sounds familiar and then of course we
have our bronchiole that feeds into this
and that that might have branched off
from another one that feeds into another
set of alveolar sacs but i don't want to
get too focused on that i covered that
in the last video but let me label it
bronchiole
bronchiole and then these are alveoli
these are
alveoli in the last video we saw
that air when we breathe in when our
diaphragm contracts and makes our lungs
expand and fill up that space air comes
in
air comes in and that air that comes in
is going to be
as we're breathing atmospheric air it's
going to be 20 21
oxygen
and it's going to be
nitrogen
nitrogen and actually in our atmosphere
carbon dioxide is actually almost a
trace gas it's less than one percent so
it's less
let me make that it's less than one
percent
carbon dioxide so anytime you breathe in
on earth this is what you're going to
get
and we said that in the last video that
you have these capillaries these
pulmonary capillaries that are running
all along the side of these alveoli so
let me draw those pulmonary
capillaries and so when they are
deoxygenated so they come here to be
oxygenated so when they're deoxygenated
they might look a little purplish
so when they're deoxygenated they might
look a little purplish and they're
running along the side of these alveoli
and then they pick up the oxygen from
inside the alveolar the oxygen diffuses
across the membrane of the alveoli into
these capillaries into these super small
tubes and then once they do that makes
the blood red and i'm going to talk in a
little bit about why it becomes red
so then it becomes red
and now that the blood is red it has its
oxygen the whole point is get the oxygen
it's ready to go back to the heart
it's ready to go back to the heart so
that's just one little part of it and we
learned in the last video that something
that goes away from the heart so this is
going away from the heart that is an
artery
a for away
and something that's going towards the
heart is a vein
so this right here
is
is a vein
now
one question and this is this actually
came up in the last video someone asked
which i think is a a very good question
is gee you know when we breathe in we
most of the air is nitrogen only 21 is
oxygen what happens to all that nitrogen
there how come that doesn't go into our
blood and that's actually an excellent
question so to answer that i think that
actually helps explain what's going on
here let's draw a little bit bigger
so let me draw
let me draw the alveolar membrane a
little bit bigger like that so this is
the inside of my of an alveolus this is
its membrane right here super thin maybe
one almost one cell thick
and then you have a capillary
you have a capillary running right next
to it so let me do that in a neutral
color so you have a capillary that's
maybe running right along this surface
so this is its capital the capillary
that's running right along the surface
just like that
just like that and this is porous to
gases like oxygen nitrogen carbon
dioxide and what we have here let's say
that this is so the heart is over here
the heart is over here so this is blood
coming from the heart and then this is
going to go back to the heart well the
heart's on both sides so let me write it
this way from the heart
from the heart and to
the heart
and what you have here is when we're
coming from the heart this is
deoxygenated blood and it's actually
going to have a high concentration of
carbon dioxide so let me draw carbon
dioxide
uh well let me draw carbon dioxide it's
green
i already did nitrogenous green let me
do carbon dioxide as orange so these are
little these there's a lot of carbon
dioxide and actually carbon dioxide
actually gets diffused in the blood it
actually is carried in the plasma of the
blood it's not carried by red blood
cells that we're going to talk about in
a second so that's a bunch of carbon
dioxide here
and there the concentration of carbon
dioxide in the deoxygenated blood is
going to be higher than the
concentration of carbon dioxide in
the alveolus so if this is porous to
carbon dioxide this membrane and it is
these carbon dioxide molecules are going
to diffuse
they're going to diffuse into into the
alveolus
now on the other side of that we have
oxygen
we have oxygen here
we're breathing it in the air is 21
oxygen so you're actually going to have
a lot more oxygen than carbon dioxide
and this is deoxygenated blood we used
all of the oxygen in our body and we'll
talk more about that
either at the end of this video or in a
future video on how we use it but or
where it goes in our body but there's no
oxygen here so the oxygen is going to be
taken it's going to it's going to
diffuse across this membrane
it's going to diffuse across this
membrane because the concentration of
oxygen is low now the question is so
immediately you see that as the oxygen
diffuses across this membrane all of a
sudden this is oxygenated blood ready to
go back to the heart this is so you know
this transition between artery and vein
is a very subtle thing you know very
clearly here you say that okay this is
going from the heart this is
this is our vein
this is going to the heart oh sorry me i
always get confused this is going away
from the heart and i was looking for an
a and i wrote from this is away from the
heart so this is an artery
and this is going to the heart so this
is a vein so you could make the division
you could say okay once it's oxygenated
maybe we're going back to the heart but
it's kind of an arbitrary sorry i spelt
artery wrong
these are these are my flaws artery
spelling was never my strong suit so you
it's it's hard to say where the artery
ends and the vein begins a good
demarcation is when the carbon dioxide
concentration goes low and that the
oxygen concentration goes high that's a
good time where we start from the
pulmonary artery
and i want to in a probably in the next
video i will make a very you'll see why
the pulmonary arteries are special
because pulmonary arteries coming away
from the heart have no oxygen or very
little oxygen and they have a lot of
carbon dioxide well pulmonary veins
so pulmonary
pulmonary
veins which is you know it's it's
arbitrary when the artery turns into a
vein because once it gets oxygenated
it's ready to go back to the heart it's
a vein it's a pulmonary vein and it is
oxygenated so it has oxygenated
oxygenated
and we could write d
now the reason why i say it's special
besides the fact that pulmonary arteries
and veins go
to and from the lungs is that they're
kind of the opposite because in the rest
of the body when we're going away from
the heart or we're talking about
arteries you're going to see that that's
oxygenated blood while when we're going
away from the heart to the lungs that's
deoxygenated blood similarly in the rest
of the body when we're going to the
heart we're going to see that that's
deoxygenated blood but in the pulmonary
vein when we're going to the heart it's
oxygenated because the the lungs are
what
take up the carbon dioxide and give us
the oxygen now i still haven't answered
that that interesting question that rose
on the on the message board on the last
on the last video what happens to the 78
of nitrogen that's sitting here so
there's just a ton of nitrogen over here
there's just a ton more than
more than the oxygen and a lot more than
the carbon dioxide what happens to all
of these nitrogen molecules and the
answer is nitrogen can diffuse and does
diffuse into the blood
but the blood's ability to
take in nitrogen isn't that high and you
might say well you know why isn't why is
oxygen special why why can the blood
take up oxygen so much easier than
nitrogen and that's where the red blood
cells come into play let me write this
down write it in red
red
blood cells
which are fascinating on a whole set of
levels
red blood cells so what red blood cells
these are these cells that are
sitting in that they're flowing through
our flowing through our circulatory
system and they look kind of like
lozenges if i were to draw one so they
kind of have the kind of like a like a
flattened sphere with a little divot on
either side of it a lot like a like a
lozenge so if i were to draw it from the
side it might look something like well
for the side it would look like that and
if you could see through it there'd be a
little divot on each side if i were to
draw it at an angle it would look
something like this
it would look something let me it would
look like that and there'd be a little
divot on that side and there'd be
similar divot on the other side and red
blood cells and i could do a whole set
of videos just on red blood cells they
contain hemoglobin
they contain hemoglobin maybe we'll do a
whole video on hemoglobin hemoglobin are
these small proteins they're actually
they they actually are uh let me
that contain four heme groups so
hemoglobin let me draw it this way
so inside of red blood cells you have
millions of hemoglobin proteins and the
hemoglobin proteins i'll just draw them
as this they have these four heme groups
and heme groups the main component is
iron and that's why iron is so important
if you don't have enough iron you're
gonna have trouble processing oxygen in
your blood and you you your hemoglobin
won't be functional enough but it has
iron on it it has four of these heme
groups and each of these heme groups can
bond to oxygen molecules and very good
bonders of oxygen and and we're going to
see
in a little bit probably in the next
video how they release the oxygen but
this has tons this has millions of heme
groups in it and the oxygen
the oxygen diffuses across the membrane
of the red blood cells and bonds to
these little to the heme groups on your
hemoglobin
so because the red blood cells have the
hemoglobin inside of them they're like
the sponges for oxygen because
hemoglobin is so good at taking in
oxygen so the red blood cells are able
to essentially suck up all of the oxygen
out of the plasma the plasma we can view
is just the general fluid of the blood
not including the red blood cell so the
red blood cell here
the red blood cell here isn't so red and
the reason and this is the key point the
reason why it's not so red so maybe we
had a red blood cell over here and we'll
make it clear carbon dioxide for the
most part is traveling within
the plasma it gets it gets absorbed into
the actual fluid and i'll talk about in
a future video it's actually in a
slightly different form it's as carbonic
acid and that's actually key point for
how the plasma knows where to dump the
oxygen but i'll talk about that in a
future video but over here this red
blood cell has a bunch of hemoglobin
proteins in it but those hemoglobin
proteins have dumped their oxygen and
actually turns out it's the hemoglobin
that so with oxygen hemoglobin looks red
with oxygen hemoglobin looks red it
reflects red light when it doesn't have
oxygen
when it doesn't have oxygen hemoglobin
does not look red it looks kind of
purplish bluish darkish you know
something and that's why that's why in
most of your body your veins that have
deoxygenated red blood cells look kind
of bluish
so this is and the reason why it changes
color is that when the oxygen bonds to
the heme sites on the hemoglobin it
actually changes the entire conformation
the entire structure of the protein
we've seen that multiple times the whole
protein folds in such a way that all of
a sudden instead of you know purplish or
dark light being reflected now red light
is reflected and that's why red blood
cells will become red once they take the
oxygen but i'm going on a tangent the
whole point here is saying why are we
taking up so much more oxygen than
nitrogen given that there's less oxygen
in the atmosphere than nitrogen and the
key is these red blood cells these red
blood cells have these millions of
hemoglobin proteins inside of them and
they take them up and they sop up all of
the oxygen out of the plasma actually
they stop up about 98.5
of the oxygen
so 98.5 of the oxygen gets sopped up by
the red blood cells so these red blood
cells are just traveling and they're
going to go
back to the heart that they are what
make our blood red so you have this
thing hemoglobin that's sitting in red
blood cells it's sopping up all of the
oxygen so it keeps the oxygen
concentration in the actual plasma low
you have nothing like that for nitrogen
there is no cell that's sopping up the
nitrogen nitrogen does not bond to
hemoglobin so that's why oxygen is taken
up so much better than nitrogen this is
a very interesting question because you
know it's it's
it's it's a you know it's a if you just
think about how much nitrogen is it's
kind of a very natural idea
now i want to focus a little bit on the
red blood cell itself because it's
fascinating it's almost you know in in
the video on the structure of the cell i
start off saying oh you know all cells
have a membrane and they all have dna
now the fascinating thing about a red
blood cell let me zoom in i just keep
drawing the same drawing has a little
divot here
it has a little divot here
the fascinating thing about the red
blossoms i already said it has a bunch
of it has millions of hemoglobin
molecules or proteins inside of it the
fascinating thing about a red blood cell
it has no nucleus
no nucleus
and no dna
no dna this is this is mind-boggling
when i first found it i was like well
why is it a cell is it really even a
living thing and it turns out when it's
growing it does have a nucleus we all
you know all cells need a nucleus with
dna in order to generate the proteins
that build it up in order to kind of
exist and and structurally make itself
the way it needs to be made but the
whole point of a red blood cell is to
contain as much hemoglobin as possible
and so you can imagine this is this was
actually a favorable evolutionary trait
that as red blood cells are ready to
kind of go into the into business you've
built the whole structure they actually
get rid of their nucleus they actually
push their nucleus out of the cell and
the whole reason why that's beneficial
is that's more space
more space for hemoglobin
more space
for hemoglobin
hemoglobin
because the more hemoglobin you have the
more oxygen you can take up and now i
can do a ton of videos on on on
hemoglobin and all of that and actually
i'm going to do a lot more on the
circulatory system so don't worry about
that but i want to go over one other
really interesting thing about
hemoglobin and we already talked about
red blood cells i think it's fascinating
that they actually don't have a nucleus
in their mature form and they actually
have very short lives they live maybe 80
120 days uh so they're not like these
long list cells that so so you know it's
almost a philosophical question are they
still alive once they've lost their dna
or are these are they just vessels
for oxygen that aren't really alive
because they aren't kind of regenerating
and producing their own dna so actually
instead of going into the hemoglobin
discussion right now i'll leave you
there in this video i realize i've been
making 20 minute videos where my goal is
really to make 10 1. so i'll leave you
here and in the next video we'll talk
more about hemoglobin and the
circulatory system